as Nora's been reporting for the past
three days we are learning incredible
stories of selflessness and courage in
the aftermath of the Las Vegas shooting
one involves a Canadian woman whose life
was saved by a Nevada man she had never
met before well they saw each other
again yesterday for the first time since
the attack Adriana Diaz was there for
the emotional reunion in her hospital
room Adriana's outside Valley Hospital
Medical Center in Las Vegas with this
story Adriana good morning good morning
the last time jan lan barton just a new
heart saw each other jan was being
rushed into surgery
justin had refused to leave her side
after finding her wounded on the ground
jan had been shot in the stomach
fracturing her pelvis
neither can remember how much time they
spent together but they now say they're
bonded for life it's been three days as
justin you heart has seen Jan lambourn
[Music]
they were strangers before the concert
where Jan says Justin saved her life
on Sunday Jan was in the crowd while
Justin Bart ended nearby when the gunman
opened fire Dan was hit in the stomach
lying wounded she had the strength to
text her husband I love you I've been
shot I love you so much
while most others fled Justin stayed
behind and saw Jan it's just instinct I
don't know I put my hand on the wound
and I start screaming medic medic he and
other strangers carried her to a nearby
field full of the injured she was
terrified I was just asking her the
silliest questions of her cats where she
was from
tell me about Canada trying to distract
her yeah
just she was in a lot of pain and I said
I would I won't leave her and she's had
a death grip it's a desperate grip that
you I cannot describe
she didn't she was always saying don't
leave me and I promised I just promised
I wouldn't leave he had stayed right
from when he found me right till I went
into the operating room
do you remember holding his hand yeah I
wasn't like go any more than he was I
think we were gonna survive this no we
did what was it like to see him really
food he was okay to him these were
strangers that treated each other like
family Jan told us she now feels like
she has another son in Justin scale I'll
say they're bonded for life thank you
Adriana take your heart and give it a
big squeeze you know it's interesting
when times like that how you rely on the
kindness of strangers just to get you
through yeah about human nature how your
instinct is to do help there helps
somebody yes I really do believe people
are mostly good than they are bad and
you see somebody in pain you do want to
help if you want to huh thank you so
much Justin Jan we're glad you're okay
you can hear more of just an and Jan's
emotional reunion today on our CBS this
morning podcast you can get it on itunes
and apple's podcast app